bridges are supposed to connect people
but War changes everything Russian
forces use this bridge to cross and the
ukrainians eventually blew it up
it remains as a reminder of the battle
for bogara dictionary now only 22 people
live here the remaining inhabitants
gathered to collect food Aid
they wait every day for volunteers from
the world Central Kitchen to deliver
meals and then traversed a twisted
concrete and gaps to cross the river and
hand it out to those eagerly waiting
there's no electricity here so we can't
cook and put things in the fridge we
need fresh food every day we've been
told the bridge will be repaired next
year
there used to be 800 people who lived
here over 100 children in the summer
families would gather along the river
those summers are now a distant memory
I built everything with my own hands of
course I will return this is my homeland
how can I abandon it the Russians did
this in a way I'm happy it burned down
and Russian forces couldn't stay here I
had a greenhouse cattle everything I
will rebuild it again with my own hands
every building has bullet holes is in
some way damaged or destroyed across the
front lines there are Villages that bear
the scars of this war the challenge the
authorities face is providing for those
that still remain and helping them
rebuild but the rebuilding can't begin
just yet fighting further east is
intense and seems to be the priority
life here is now very simple there's no
running water
I'm very grateful to the humanitarian
organizations that bring us food I
didn't even imagine this amount of help
I'll try to rebuild my house I don't
know how but right now I'll start
cleaning up the rubble on the hill
overlooking the village lies a Russian
tank it fired down on the buildings
below but just as the homes below it it
now too shares the same fate the
difference however is the Ukrainian
homes will eventually be rebuilt the
Russian tank will gather
rustera bhagra de chanea Ukraine